[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o pé
olá a todos
contava dizer peço desculpa não consegue
estar tempo vou ter mesmo falar
assentada não levem a mal mas pensem no
lado positivo estamos todos sentados
logo pé de igualdade
só que neste caso eu falo e você jovem
neste momento vocês devem estar aí a
pensar o que será que aconteceu
será que foi acidente ou será que já
assistiu assim ai que pena era tão linda
que vinha tão jovem tanta coisa que não
pode fazer nada já estão a pensar e e
parece já tá que ela tem para dizer no
texas um chavo
aos 11 anos e foi vítima de um acidente
na minha escola
este já respondendo uma dessas questões
que estão a mergulhar nas costas de
cabeças
basicamente na altura os autocarros
entrava dentro do recinto escolar para
ver maior segurança
mas adivinhem o que o mesmo portão de
entrada para os autocarros também servia
de entrada para as pessoas que não
usavam o autocarro rumo da história
basicamente foi esmagada contra um
portão na parte lateral esquerda do
autocarro ou seja do lado do condutor
que não colheu para o espelho e aqui eu
já provei da minha toca para lançar o
alerta da importância nós usamos os pés
dos carros não para maquiagem nem para
fazer a barba
mas para evitar mesmo grave acidente
mas calma no meio desta história
dramática at an existe um lado positivo
é que o autocarro não sofreu nenhum
engenhão
afinal eu fui uma boa almofada após meu
acidente
eu já tô carros foram retirados do
centro escolar a ser aberto um novo
portão específico para as pessoas e hoje
em dia nem sequer o carro do lixo entrar
no recinto escolar
é aquela velha sabedoria que depois de
casa roubada trancas à porta
enfim há um fator já perceberam porque a
minha vida sobre rodas como costumo
dizer mas muitas vezes as pessoas têm
alguma dificuldade motora são
bombardeados com um conjunto pergunta
gira afirmações exemplo típico
então o que aconteceu o acidente
sim daqui como é que foi já com vai
controlar a curiosidade e acabar com o
interrogatório porque primeiro porque já
se percebeu o que aconteceu com o
objetivo da questão certo é acidente
depois também temos o fato de ser um
acontecimento do passado
ninguém quer estar constantemente a
trazer esse acontecimento o presente e
também sejamos sinceros ninguém gosta de
ser bombardeado com perguntas
principalmente se forem pessoas imaginem
alguém que vocês não conhecem lado
nenhum
chega nos agora de repente perguntam
então tu trabalhas e que trabalha e com
a de campanhas alguma prudência
fundamental
ai que pena ela era tão linda
mas por acaso a beleza é um fator que
evita acidentes ou doenças não gordos
altos magros feios e bonitos
todos podem vir a sofrer o acidente nem
está imundo e já agora é o facto de uma
pessoa ter uma dificuldade motora a
torna menos bonita eu deixo a questão no
ar para foi termos ayala se deus quis
assim já estava destinada
bem primeiro cd deus existisse nós
acreditamos na sua existência de escalar
quer a nossa alegria a nossa felicidade
na tua virou crer o sofrimento e
provocar nos mal
é quase como dizer que deus nos provoca
os divórcios os problemas financeiros é
de guerras então eu quero bem vai causar
um mal entendido na playdom antes de a
vida ser um fator protetor timbó já
estava destinado a licença devida por
acaso não é uma novela que já temos um
guião já está tudo definido ou ela é
feita de escolhas de momentos era
escrita em um acidente é um facto
excluir a escola
o problema com todas as outras crianças
noé e os outros desde que fazia o
problema e que foi apanhada no momento
errado
ae
gosto de uma coisa é mais feliz agora do
que antes de estar melhor agora
e confesso que estas duas perguntas
fazem um bocadinho de confusão
isso é que há pessoas que dizem que
depois de um acidente do mando de uma
desgraça são mais felizes valorizam mais
a vida mas felizmente há pessoas que já
faziam isso sem terem que necessitar de
uma desgraça
sim as pessoas precisam levar uma
bofetada da vida para começarem a pensar
olha valoriza portões do que ash
mas nem todas as pessoas são iguais com
vai não rotular os porque os rótulos são
projeto alimento e não para as pessoas
ser vítimas de um acidente é motivo para
parar não de todo
é motivo pra nós formularmos os nossos
sonhos e aproveitarmos as ferramentas
que temos de dar como costumo dizer o
máximo dos novos máximos
neste caso no meu caso em particular os
meus sonhos e agora tem que ser
excessivas é minha condição é fácil
não não é fácil mas por causa da vida é
fácil é vida é difícil e não vale a pena
dizer o contrário se alguém algum de vos
dizer que a vida é fácil é claramente
publicidade enganosa
todos nós vamos ter obstáculos
vamos ter desafios e vamos ter momentos
de dor sem dúvida mas felizmente nós
temos o poder de decidir se vamos sofrer
com essa dor ou minimizá la
e nessa vida está sempre ensinando os
aliás eu não percebo como é que um
episódio da vida não está no primeiro
lugar do ranking das melhores
universidades do mundo
a série tudo apenas na teoria pra ser
aplicadas não tô vez disso leva sua
prática do curso ficas coleção com
experiência
alguém que se imagina numa cadeira de
rodas não se é muito infecção e isso
assusta dá muito medo
precisamos de ajuda claro que precisamos
de ajuda mas todos nós possamos de ajuda
e é bom ajudar nos uns aos outros
muitas vezes eu ouço aquela expressão
olha eu não sei ajudar por isso aqui não
ajuda
não vou para lá trabalhar mas por que
não dizer assim precisa de ajuda
e como é que eu posso ajudá lo ali não
saiu do ar mas sim explicar eu te dou um
jeitinho torna tudo mais fácil quando
temos a ajuda de dois outros eu falar de
ajuda prestada ajuda falaria das
barreiras arquitetônicas é que o grande
obstáculo um dos maiores obstáculos das
pessoas com mobilidade reduzida
mas se nós pensarmos bem as bactérias
arquitetônicas existem porque nós é que
construímos a nossa falta de consciência
os prédios das ruas nas construções
sozinhos não somos nós
falta aquela empatia aquela capacidade
pensarmos nos outros mais do que pensar
nos colocarmos no lugar do outro
vamos fazer um breve exercício imaginem
querem construir um prédio na entrada do
prédio pensam em colocar aquelas portas
de empurrar o chá e sentar em uma
cadeira de rodas
será que vocês conseguem abrir a porta e
ao mesmo tempo conduzir a cadeira vai
ser um bocadinho difícil provavelmente
vão precisar de ajuda e que tal portas
automáticas ou daquelas do correto até
um pai com um carrinho de bebê tem a
vida mais simples na entrada do nosso
prédio estão a pensar colocar alguns
degraus pois andar em cadeira de rodas
há já saiu uma rampa pronto resolvido o
problema
certo mas a rampa foi muito inclinada
não vão conseguir subir sozinhos vão
precisar de quase como se estivesse ali
os degraus piso relaxava imagina silva
ou então sim uma rampa mas com uma
inclinação adequada pois ela é a volta
do nosso prédio
vamos ter ruas vamos ter para sair certo
quando o pavimento que nós vamos usar
nos passeios em calçada portuguesa tão
linda que é ea tradição é importante
mantermos a tradição pois o desafio de
andar em uma cadeira de rodas sobre a
calçada
quer muito maior diz que o esforço
físico e não ao tio não é o mais
adequado
continuamos na construção do nosso
prédio
vamos ter a dar certo precisamos do
valor que você não gostei muito sincera
isso pudesse usar máscaras queimavam
mais calorias e não correr o risco de
ficar presa em um elevador caso eu
haveria o que acontece muitas vezes eo
pago com o valor cheio de pessoas que
não cedem lugar a uma pessoa que o pacto
precisa do valor
daí ter havido necessidade de criar
aquelas bonequinhas de dizer acesso
prioritário algo que muitas vezes é
ignorada
e aí meus amigos não é falta de
consciência é mesmo uma bactéria mental
depois no nosso prédio o que nós vamos
licitar parques de estacionamento
já repararam que os lugares reservados
para cadeira de rodas são mais espaçosos
dos conjuntos certo e não não é porque
nós não sabemos estacionar em lugares
mais estreitos é porque o facto
precisamos de mais espaço para fazer a
transferência cadeira carro e vice versa
a porta tem que abrir completamente o
que queremos para muitas vezes carros
estacionados sem o teste com sim porque
nós pra assinar neste temos que ser
portadores do instituto tem que estar
visível no pára brisas é assim eu quero
acreditar sinceramente
que as pessoas que estacionam aí sem
disco não é falta de consciência nenhuma
barreira mental
elas simplesmente não consegue
estacionar num sítio mais estreito
pronto
é esse o problema nesta manhã temos até
os carros que têm diz tico
só que há aqui um problema o destino é
atribuído a qualquer pessoa que tenha
uma data em capacidade
se uma pessoa tiver uma incapacidade da
testada pelo menos 60% já pode
estacionar belém mas não será que esse
lugar devendo ser reservados apenas para
quem de fato precisa mais passo é porque
a oferta neste lugar já é muito limitada
não sei se já repararam mas viu até
agora não usei a palavra deficiente e
sabem porquê
normalmente a palavra deficiente tem um
sentido negativo
quantas e quantas vezes não é usada
quase como um insulto então que estas
chaves de casa que o eficiente do oeste
não pode fazer isto é as mesmas
eficiente é que os lugares suficientes
não os lugares são para pessoas com
necessidades especiais
sim porque dada sua condição da sua
mobilidade reduzida têm a necessidade
especial de ter um lugar mais espaçoso
com os outros para conseguir entrar e
sair do carro
mesmo aquelas pessoas com algum problema
mental ambiente chamado deficientes são
pessoas com necessidades educativas
especiais
são pessoas que precisam de uma atenção
personalizada
daí o especial é importante nós termos
em mente que estas pessoas já lidam com
tantas batalhas no seu dia-a-dia e o
simples facto de conseguirem adaptar
essas situações serem flexíveis para
ultrapassar tudo já que os obstáculos e
tentarem tornar mais fácil é que o que
já é difícil só as tornam muito muito
eficiente tomar todos temos a mesma
força para dar conta dos desafios da
vida
agora que já terminamos a construção do
nosso prédio tem que falar dos das
minhas viagens de avião
sim porque isto de viver numa ilha e
estudar no porto obrigou uma viagem
constante sou nutricionista assim e já
estou a ver você já ia pensar em bairro
quando o atual terminar e rui de
parreira dela pública de nutrição
passarem aqui plant esqueçam no estudo
melhorar o trabalho mas preferem mesmo
pois podemos agendar uma consulta
continuar
os aeroportos têm funcionários
específicos que nos prestam assistência
no embarque e no desembarque sua
primeira entrar no avião o que obriga
sempre a chegar mais cedo e para ser sua
última e qual é o problema
eu não consigo usar as casas de banho do
avião são minúsculas
já entre o avião aterrar saírem todos os
passageiros virá assistência
lá se vai uma hora assim companhias
aéreas ser a primeira ser seria uma
excelente ajuda durante a minha estadia
no porto eu tive que recorrer a uma a
uma cadeira elétrica
ela nos dá mais autonomia só que é
imagem flexível não consegue subir e
descer por exemplo degraus naquela
manual facilmente conseguimos contornar
esta situação o que fazemos podemos
ajudar mas numa cadeira que pesa mais ou
menos 90 quilos mais complicado do que
acontecia
carros estacionados em cima do passeio
sabe o que isso muitas vezes me obrigava
a ter que voltar para trás até encontrar
um piso rebaixado ou uma tampa
normalmente nas passadeiras quando tem
nem todas têm e depois ter que fazer o
mesmo percurso mais plano estrada
juntamente com os carros em dias de
chuva torrencial garantiu hoje que
espera um espetáculo como devem imaginar
aquela ideia pessoal de lá não tem um
lugar de estacionamento que estacionam
em cima do passeio não atrapalha ninguém
é errado podem atrapalhar e muito a vida
de alguém
como era uma situação recorrente
acontecia muitas vezes jantava obrigar a
primeira ter que sair mais cedo casa se
durava dez minutos para a faculdade e já
sei 20 minutos antes que lava posso ter
um carro estacionado em cima do passeio
eu não vou tomar uma atitude
contactar a câmara do porto cuja
situação e em tempo recorde e não era
ano de eleições
lá parceiro mais pisos rachados rampas e
colocar um ferros que impediam o
direcionamento e não tinha conhecido a
mãe sabe uma história engraçada onde
vinha da faculdade e vinha dos rapazes
da minha frente e um vírus por outra
eles já visto que os fizeram usando
aquilo a lei agora já não consegue
estacionar onde é que vão estacionar o
carro e eles mal sabiam que a
responsável de que ele estava mesmo
atrás deus
bem isto agora eles vão ficar a saber
isso favor organização corta esta parte
não tenho lugar tem que estacionar mais
longe caminhão mais fazem mais atividade
física só é benéfico para a vossa saúde
a série palavra da nutricionista
por falar em saúde
eu gostaria de dizer que o fato é que o
estudo os benefícios da atividade física
da prática regular de exercício também
se aplicam a lógica do absurdo escolas e
mais é fundamental nós temos uma vida
ativa
nós passamos muitas horas sentados temos
que investir mais na atividade física
só que uma percebo que ainda uma falta
de consciência nesse sentido
onde estão os ginásios adaptados os pt
de pune veis para trabalhar com pessoas
com mobilidade reduzida aulas do zumba
adaptada de cross fit china para
praticar natação
o fato ainda temos um longo caminho no
trecho que vai da integração inclusive
na saúde ea sério e eu também quero
tirar aquelas fotos de filhos no ginásio
pública nas redes sociais e light
nem se uma pessoa é discriminada
francamente eu percebo a grande mensagem
que quero deixar é que vocês antes de
pensarem antes de dirigirem de falar em
pensar em sempre esforço comigo é da
próxima vez quando tiverem num evento
cheio de pessoas e à vossa frente uma
pessoa com mobilidade reduzida
se derem o vosso lugar vocês podem usar
as escadas e aquela pessoa
obrigatoriamente tem que usar o elevador
é da próxima vez que forem ao shopping e
todos os lugares estiverem ocupados -
aqui hoje para cadeira de rodas pensar
em não vos funcionar a lei porque posso
vir a complicar a vida de alguém que já
tenha uma vida complicada mundo massiva
mais inclusivo é possível que as
mentalidades não são estáticas todas
aquelas barreiras podem ser eliminadas
se nós combateremos a falta de
consciência e as barreiras mentais
então é isso
obrigada
[Aplausos]